die live nach kirche zu unserem reporter
paul ronzheimer der dort heute unterwegs
war unterwegs ist muss man sagen paul du
stehst immer noch im stau
damals wenn die lage nicht so ernst wäre
nicht so brisant wenn ich gerade die
nachrichten gekommen wären dass russland
kurz davor steht das geheimnis gebäude
im zentrum der stadt anzugreifen dann
würde ich in so einer situation lachen
denn es sind eigentlich nur ein
kilometer für die ich jetzt schon drei
stunden brauche was und es liegt daran
dass hier geht s auto gefilzt wird jedes
auto kontrolliert sie haben angst davor
dass jemand ein russischer provokateur
in die stadt kommt hier über diese
brücke das ist die brücke und ja gerade
die videos gezeigt
das ist nicht genau hier passiert die
helikopter abschluss abschluss ein
bisschen weiter weg auf einer anderen
brücke aber es ist genau der fluss und
wir haben das gefühl dass es ernst
werden könnte wir haben eine menge
krankenwagen gesehen die an uns vorbei
gerauscht sind in einem massiven tempo
ich habe schon erwähnen die meldungen
die russische nachrichtenagentur die
dort regierungskreise zitiert und sagt
dass russland kurz davor stünde vor
einem streik gegen die ukrainische ding
das ukrainische geheimdienst gebäude
also man hat das gefühl dass sich doch
die situation hier beitrag
weiter eskaliert weil wir sehen auch
hier unten rechts im bild diesen
russischen militär konvoi auf dem weg
nach kef in die hauptstadt er soll eine
länge von sage und schreibe 64 kilometer
haben also panzer artillerie logistik
truppentransporter was kannst du uns
darüber berichten wie nah ist dieser
konvoi mittlerweile an die hauptstadt
heran
ja der konvoi kommt immer näher wobei
möglicherweise das ganze auch so ein
bisschen ein ablenkungsmanöver sein
könnte denn in wahrheit wird russland
erst mal mit raketen im rein schießen
und luftangriffen kommen das haben sie
jetzt auch angekündigt dieser konvoi
diese tanker diese panzer diese
truppentransporter die würden ja es
wären das dann dort wenn ist sozusagen
wirklich in die stadt geht und das
bleibt abzuwarten wieder die
militärische strategie ist natürlich
sorgt dieser konvoi für angst und bange
hirnhälfte natürlich wissen die menschen
dass rein von der technologie von den
panzern von alldem
russland der ukraine überlegen ist egal
wie heldenhaft die verteidigung ist egal
wie viele menschen jetzt ein gewehr
haben und sich damit ausgerüstet haben
wenn dann diese panzer gemütlich durch
rollen sollten dann wird es sehr
schwierig für die ukraine sein zu
verteidigen allerdings würde das auch
bedeuten dass putin wirklich bereit ist
auch kiew als stadt zu stören paul in
diesem moment kommt eine eilmeldung
herein die die viele ukraine
wahrscheinlich freuen dürfte die
europäische union nämlich den ukraine
antrag diesen schnell antrag auf die
mitgliedschaft in die europäische union
an das wird bedeutet natürlich noch
nicht dass die ukraine jetzt schon
eu-mitglied ist aber das verfahren läuft
jetzt offiziell an
ja das ist eine positive eine gute
nachricht allerdings ist es schwer für
jeden ukraine hier sich darüber zu
freuen in so einer situation ich
erinnere mich wie 2014 dort die
europäischen flaggen gehisst wurden
dabei dann mit hunderttausenden menschen
heute wird niemand haupt den platz gehen
können was zu friedenszeiten gegangen
wäre
und es ist so eine sekunde ich muss mal
kurz danach verurteilt
okay es war nachrichten die mitmach
aktiv zu tun haben
es ist so dass ja normalerweise bei so
einer entscheidung thomas werden jetzt
die
freudentaumel auf den straßen und auf
den plätzen denn das ist ja das was sich
die ukraine immer gewünscht hat und die
bekommen hat der vorherige präsident
juschtschenko und dann auch selensky
erst jetzt wo das land muss man sagen
nicht nur am abgrund steht mit in einem
brutalen krieg gegen russland
mitten in einem krieg in dem zivilisten
sterben kinder sterben frauen sterben in
dem einen ganzen land die existenz
genommen werden soll ist das nur noch
ein
kleines zeichen dass sicherlich wichtig
ist ich will das nicht runter reden aber
am ende
am ende ist es nichts was hier leben
geschützt wird paul gibt uns doch noch
mal kurz einen überblick über die lage
für die menschen die noch in kiew
geblieben sind ja wie ist die versorgung
mittlerweile am supermarkt überhaupt
noch geöffnet wie können sich die
menschen überhaupt ein becken mit wasser
mit lebensmitteln
der wir waren heute mittag im supermarkt
aber lange lange schlangen und die
menschen die ausgaben haben mir erzählt
dass bestimmte lebensmittel schon nicht
mehr da sind dass sie die nicht mehr
bekommen dass man lange lange anstehen
muss da wird rationiert auch beim benzin
wir haben nur noch zehn liter bekommen
mit unserem auto um sozusagen ja die den
dass mehr menschen beliefert werden
können also das wird knapp und das wird
natürlich immer im
heftiger werden dadurch
dass hier die die lebensmittel leben
knapp werden dass sozusagen der kreis
der kessel der darauf gelegt wird von
wladimir putin möglicherweise enger wird
und es dann kein durchkommen mehr gibt
hier sehen wir auch die bilder lange
schlangen vor supermärkten heute morgen
und auch leere regale fielen dank paul
wir gehen direkt weiter zu peter heller
bild reporter der ebenfalls in kiew ist
bitter
erzählt uns was über diese
versorgungssituation diese langen
schlangen die wir da jetzt sehen vor
einem großen supermarkt und dem auch
leere regale auf der anderen seite
also ich kann das bestätigen dass paul
gesagt hat hier hat eigentlich gar kein
geschäft mehr auf weil es ist
geschlossen die straßen sind
menschenleer
ab und zu sieht man ein paar gestalten
aus dem haus rutschen vielleicht wird
hier getauscht oder wie auch immer also
man hat versucht sich einzudecken vorher
natürlich auch schon sieht so aus dass
die versorgungslage halt drastisch
schlimmer sich verschlimmern wird weil
wir haben auch heute versucht
irgendetwas zu bekommen benzin oder auch
wasser und dergleichen das gibt es auch
nicht mehr also es ist das wird von tag
zu tag schlimmer und die lage innerhalb
der stadt wird auch gespenstisch wir
waren heute am bahnhof dort finden nach
wie vor extremer flucht bewegung statt
das die leute raus möchten heute morgen
ging es jetzt soll es wieder stärker
gewesen seien die züge sind gekommen da
spricht sich relativ schnell rum aber
wir schalten oder wie schwingt mal ganz
kurz herunter man sieht unten links
auch eine ein checkpoint also jede
straße wird jetzt im prinzip
kontrolliert die angst dass großen
einfallen sabotage trupps ist sehr hoch
es gab eine warnung dass die
telekommunikations stellen hier in kiew
angegriffen werden sollen ob das jetzt
vom von von den nachrichtendiensten sind
oder vom innenministerium oder
dergleichen also alles was mit
telekommunikation zu tun hat soll
angegriffen werden jetzt in den nächsten
zeiten das heißt das also die
eskalationsstufe immer höher geht jetzt
was den
angriffsmodus angeht also man will jetzt
hingehen also die kommunikation des
gegners und der ukraine auszuschalten
und das bedeutet nichts gutes der kreis
schließt sich immer enger und die große
angst jetzt in kiew ist das eben der
letzte korridor nämlich der weg nach
west nach lemgo die einzige hauptstraße
die noch frei ist wenn die eingenommen
wird dann war's das mit kiew dann kommt
ihr nichts mehr rein und dann geht auch
nichts mehr raus weder autos noch
lebensmittel noch irgendetwas anderes
und dann hätten die russen das was sie
haben wollten nämlich eine komplett
isolierte statt wenn sie dann noch den
flughafen haben dann hätten sie einen
brückenkopf und dann würde es hier eine
art aushungerung szenario geben oder was
noch schlimmer ist dass viele befürchten
dass sie dann wirklich hier rein
bombardieren um die stadt zu zermürben
um kiew als quasi als faustpfand für
verhandlungen zu nehmen und zu sagen
okay wir spielen ja mit dieser stadt wir
haben sie bei uns in unseren händen
bitte macht das was wir wollen sonst
können wir die daumenschrauben die
eskalationsstufe immer noch mehr erhöhen
also peter informations anlagen du sagst
es die zerstört werden sollen was würde
das ja in dem schrecklichen fall für
unsere berichterstattung bedeuten
das weiß ich nicht also wir hatten uns
alles schon gewundert dass ist noch
nicht stattgefunden hat normalerweise
ist es üblich hinkriegen dass
normalerweise werden angriffe geflogen
werden geht weder internet noch handy
noch irgendetwas anderes werden dann
stört die esb sachen werden eingesetzt
dh da kann man sich überhaupt nicht mehr
miteinander da kann man gar nicht mehr
kommunizieren wenn man pech hat können
wir gar nicht mehr miteinander sprechen
dann oder telefonieren es geht dann nur
noch über satellit und das ja dann wird
schwierig auch mit der übertragung der
informationen und dergleichen das ist ja
der sinn der übung den mann dann hat das
wollen natürlich auch die russen nicht
das dann hier in der ukraine
untereinander kommuniziert wird das
truppen oder das eben auch bürger wehren
oder auch die die milizen sich hier in
der stadt kommunikativ verschieben
können dann greift man wieder zum alten
funk und das wird wahrscheinlich die
letzte lösung sondern hier wieder was
was du sie über die situation in anderen
teilen des landes sind aktiv
beispielsweise wurde heute morgen eine
regierungsgebäude von einer rakete
angegriffen wir haben die bilder vorhin
unten rechts kleinen fenster gesehen die
rakete hat das gebäude direkt mich
getroffen schlug kurz vorher auf der
straße eines gebäudes steht auch noch
aber fenster und so weiter sind heraus
auch von anderen teilen wird gemeldet
aus der ukraine
dass die situation immer dramatischer
wird die russischen behörden
beispielsweise russisches
verteidigungsministerium behauptet und
wir müssen dazu sagen diese
informationen können wir nicht
nachprüfen dass die ukraine komplett vom
schwarzen vom ars auction mehr dass es
dann eben mehr des schwarzen meeres
abgeschnitten ist also dort wo städte
wie mario pohl beispielsweise sind
also diese information wir bekommen
dasselbe was ihr bekommt das ist eben
das schlimme an dieser sache es sind
natürlich immer gerüchte die hier
auftauchen das sind meistens aber
informationen über bombenanschläge
und und bombardements was gerade
getroffen worden ist wir hatten heute
morgen ebenfalls gehört dass außerhalb
also 30 kilometer außerhalb hinter uns
einen einen krankenhaus bombardiert
worden ist das hatte sich natürlich
nicht bestätigt also das sind diese
truppen verschiebungen das ist halt das
große geheimnis wo überhaupt die front
verläuft da tut natürlich die ukraine
auch gut daran das nicht zu
kommunizieren die russen kommunizieren
sowieso nichts und für uns als
berichterstatter ist das überhaupt nicht
verifizierbar wo
eine
frontverlauf ist wo man überhaupt sieht
dass sich truppen bewegen das einzige
worauf wir auch angewiesen sind wir sind
satellitenbilder wo wir gesehen haben
dass eben diese 60 kilometer lange linie
sich um 44 zieht mit den gepanzerten
fahrzeugen eine richtige
front wie man sie sich vorstellt die
haben wir hier bei kiew überhaupt nicht
also gibt es wird von außen wird gebombt
oder es kommt marschflugkörper rein
es gibt also wahrscheinlich gar nicht so
eine richtige front wo sich die stellung
gegenüber wo sich die truppen
gegenüberliegen es sind immer so
ausfallerscheinungen dann verschiebt
sich das ganze und das macht es alles so
schwierig überhaupt hier noch lesen zu
können auch für die menschen die noch
raus wollen man kann es nicht lesen man
weiß nicht mehr wo man hinfahren muss
nach rechts nach links nach norden nach
süden nach westen welche straße ist ich
welche straße wird vielleicht gerade von
einem von einer drohne beobachtet von
einer russischen lkws haben wir gesehen
es sind lkw sie hier reingekommen sind
in die stadt die haben vermutlich keine
lebensmittel transportiert sondern
vermutlich waffen oder dergleichen und
das sind alles potenzielle ziele und die
warten natürlich auch darauf wo sie
hinfahren können genauso wie wir wenn
wir irgendwo hinfahren wir wissen auch
nicht können wir geradeaus weiterfahren
oder nach links oder nach rechts und ich
glaube das große problem wird sein wenn
man dann irgendwann mal aus der stadt
raus will was ist da noch sicher oder
auch die leute die hier reinkommen in
die stadt um noch weiter zu versorgen
das wird alles sehr schwierig sein
paul hat es gerade schon gesagt das
größte problem wird dann die
versorgungslage seien mit benzin das
kommt dann natürlich auch nicht mehr
hier ein ebenso lebensmittel und andere
noten und notwendigkeiten die man hier
für das alltägliche leben braucht also
die menschen die hier jetzt
verbleiben den
da schwant böses also das wird hier
nicht so lustig ausgehen und das wissen
die leute auch wieder hell vielen danke
für den moment nach kiel